لطالما اتُهمت روسيا باستخدام
الطاقة كسلاح ، وهذا
الإعلان الأخير يثير الدهشة ،
وأغلقت قنبلة غاز نوردستروم أحد
خط أنابيب رئيسي لنقل الغاز إلى أوروبا في وقت سابق من هذا
الأسبوع لمدة ثلاثة أيام من الصيانة ، والآن بعد
أن فاجأ هذا الإعلان السوق
بالنظر إلى أن خط الأنابيب كان  لقد
خضعوا مؤخرًا لإغلاق صيانة مجدولة لمدة 10 أيام
يوم الجمعة في
المساء قبل أن يتم
إرجاعه على جازبروم ، وقالوا إنهم
اكتشفوا تسربًا للزيت في محطة ضاغط
وأطلقوا الصورة التي تراها هنا
واستمروا في بيان يقول
حتى  تم حل المشكلات المتعلقة بتشغيل
المعدات ، حيث تم إيقاف إمدادات الغاز إلى
خط أنابيب الغاز
نوردستروم تمامًا ، حيث يمثل
الغاز الروسي أكبر مستهلك للغاز في روسيا ، حيث استحوذ الغاز الروسي
على حوالي 35 من
واردات الغاز في العام الماضي ، وقد
حاول البلوك تقليل اعتماده عليه
الغاز الروسي منذ غزو أوكرانيا
يملأ منشآت التخزين ويستورد
المزيد من أماكن أخرى لكنه سيظل كذلك  هروب
من أجل اجتياز هذا الشتاء إذا
لم تستأنف روسيا الإمدادات عبر خط الأنابيب
نوردستروم واحد الآن من
الصعب تجاهل توقيت هذا الإعلان
قبل ساعات قليلة من إعلان جازبروم عن
أكبر اقتصادات الغرب
وافقت مجموعة الدول السبع على فرض حد أقصى لسعر
النفط الروسي  وفقًا لتحليل بروجيل ،
تكسب روسيا حاليًا أكثر من 600 مليون
دولار يوميًا من النفط ويمكن أن تحقق
عائدات سنوية قياسية من النفط والغاز
هذا العام الآن.
الحرب في أوكرانيا ولكن بينما لا تزال
تسمح ببيع النفط الروسي في
السوق وبالتالي لا تقلل الإمدادات العالمية ،
فقد هددت روسيا بالفعل
بالرد على أي سقف لأسعار النفط وفقًا
لمهمة وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية ، قال
نائب رئيس الوزراء ألكسندر نوفاك
للصحفيين إننا ببساطة لن نفعل ذلك.
توريد منتجات النفط والبترول
لهذه الشركات أو الدول التي تفرض
قيودًا لأننا لن نعمل بشكل
غير تنافسي  توقفت روسيا بالفعل
عن تصدير الغاز إلى عدد من
الدول الغربية بسبب مشكلات الدفع
وقبل إغلاق خط الأنابيب الأخير ، كان خط
نوردستروم
يعمل فقط بقدرة 20 سعته ، وهو غاز آخر يتراجع
إذا ظل خط الأنابيب غير متصل ومن
المحتمل أن يكون النفط كذلك إذا كانت
اتفاقية مجموعة الدول السبع.  يتم تنفيذ هذا الحد الأقصى وقد تؤدي
ردود روسيا الانتقامية
إلى ارتفاع أسعار الطاقة باستمرار مما
يؤدي إلى زيادة التضخم ويهدد بدفع
الاقتصادات الكبرى إلى الركود مما يضفي
وزناً أكبر على الحجة القائلة بأن روسيا
تستخدم الطاقة كسلاح آنا ستيوارت CNN
لندن